so you've spoken a lot about the idea of
software 2.0
um all good ideas become like cliches so
quickly like the terms is it's kind of
hilarious
um it's like I think Eminem once said
that like if he gets annoyed by a song
He's written very quickly that means
it's going to be a big hit because it's
it's too catchy but uh can you describe
this idea and how you're thinking about
it has evolved over the months and years
since since you coined it yeah
yeah so I had a blog post on software
2.0 I think several years ago now
um
and the reason I wrote that post is
because I kept I kind of saw something
remarkable happening in
like software development and how a lot
of code was being transitioned to be
written not in sort of like C plus plus
and so on but it's written in the
weights of a neural net basically just
saying that neural Nets are taking over
software the realm of software and
taking more and more tasks and at the
time I think not many people understood
uh this uh deeply enough that this is a
big deal it's a big transition uh neural
networks were seen as one of multiple
classification algorithms you might use
for your data set problem on kaggle like
this is not that this is a change in how
we program
computers
and I saw neural Nets as uh this is
going to take over the way we program
computers is going to change it's not
going to be people writing a software in
C plus or something like that and
directly programming the software it's
going to be accumulating training sets
and data sets and crafting these
objectives by which you train these
neural Nets and at some point there's
going to be a compilation process from
the data sets and the objective and the
architecture specification into the
binary which is really just uh the
neural nut you know weights and the
forward pass of the neural net and then
you can deploy that binary and so I was
talking about that sort of transition
and uh that's what the post is about and
I saw this sort of play out in a lot of
fields uh you know Auto autopilot being
one of them but also just a simple image
classification people thought originally
you know in the 80s and so on that they
would write the algorithm for detecting
a dog in an image and they had all these
ideas about how the brain does it and
first we detect corners and then we
detect lines and then we stitched them
up and they were like really going at it
they were like thinking about how
they're going to write the algorithm and
this is not the way you build it
and there was a smooth transition where
okay first we thought we were going to
build everything then we were building
the features uh so like Hawk features
and things like that that detect these
little statistical patterns from image
patches and then there was a little bit
of learning on top of it like a support
Vector machine or binary classifier for
cat versus dog and images on top of the
features so we wrote the features but we
trained the last layer sort of the the
classifier and then people are like
actually let's not even design the
features because we can't honestly we're
not very good at it so let's also learn
the features and then you end up with
basically accommodational neural net
where you're learning most of it you're
just specifying the architecture and the
architecture has tons of fill in the
blanks which is all the knobs and you
let the optimization write most of it
and so this transition is happening
across the industry everywhere and uh
suddenly we end up with a ton of code
that is written in neural net weights
and I was just pointing out that the
analogy is actually pretty strong and we
have a lot of developer environments for
software 1.0 like we have Ides
um how you work with code how you debug
code how do you how do you run code how
do you maintain code we have GitHub so I
was trying to make those analogies in
the new realm like what is the GitHub or
software 2.0 turns out that something
that looks like hugging face right now
uh you know and so I think some people
took it seriously and built cool
companies and uh many people originally
attacked the post it actually was not
well received when I wrote it and I
think maybe it has something to do with
the title but the post was not well
received and I think more people sort of
have been coming around to it over time
yeah so you were the director of AI at
Tesla where I think this idea
was really implemented at scale which is
how you have engineering teams doing
software 2.0 so can you sort of Linger
on that idea of I think we're in the
really early stages of everything you
just said which is like GitHub Ides
like how do we build engineering teams
that that work in software 2.0 systems
and and the the data collection and the
data annotation which is
all part of that software 2.0 like what
do you think is the task of programming
a software 2.0 is it debugging in the
space of hyper parameters or is it also
debugging the space of data yeah the way
by which you program the computer and
influence its algorithm is not by
writing the commands yourself you're
changing mostly the data set uh you're
changing the um loss functions of like
what the neural net is trying to do how
it's trying to predict things but yeah
basically the data sets and the
architectures of the neural net and um
so in the case of the autopilot a lot of
the data sets have to do with for
example detection of objects and Lane
line markings and traffic lights and so
on So You accumulate massive data sets
of here's an example here's the desired
label and then uh here's roughly how the
architect here's roughly what the
algorithm should look like and that's a
conclusional neural net so the
specification of the architecture is
like a hint as to what the algorithm
should roughly look like and then the
fill in the blanks process of
optimization is the training process
and then you take your neural nut that
was trained it gives all the right
answers on your data set and you deploy
it
so there's in that case perhaps it all
machine learning cases there's a lot of
tasks
so is coming up formulating a task like
uh for a multi-headed neural network is
formulating a task part of the
programming yeah very much so how you
break down a problem into a set of tasks
yeah
I'm on a high level I would say if you
look at the software running in in the
autopilot I gave a number of talks on
this topic I would say originally a lot
of it was written in software 1.0
there's imagine lots of C plus plus
right and then gradually there was a
tiny neural net that was for example
predicting given a single image is there
like a traffic light or not or is there
a landline marking or not and this
neural net didn't have too much to do in
this in the scope of the software it was
making tiny predictions on individual
little image and then the rest of the
system stitched it up so okay we're
actually we don't have just a single
camera with eight cameras we actually
have eight cameras over time and so what
do you do with these predictions how do
you put them together how do you do the
fusion of all that information and how
do you act on it all of that was written
by humans um in C plus
and then we decided okay we don't
actually want uh to do all of that
Fusion in C plus code because we're
actually not good enough to write that
algorithm we want the neural Nets to
write the algorithm and we want to Port
uh all of that software into the 2.0
stack
and so then we actually had neural Nets
that now take all the eight camera
images simultaneously and make
predictions for all of that
so
um and and actually they don't make
predictions in a in the space of images
they now make predictions directly in 3D
and actually they don't in three
dimensions around the car and now
actually we don't
um manually fuse the predictions over in
3D over time we don't trust ourselves to
write that tracker so actually we give
the neural net uh the information over
time so it takes these videos now and
makes those predictions and so your sort
of just like putting more and more power
into the neural network processing and
at the end of it the eventual sort of
goal is to have most of the software
potentially be in 2.0 land
um because it works significantly better
humans are just not very good at writing
software basically so the prediction is
space happening in this like 4D land
yeah was three-dimensional world over
time yeah how do you
do annotation in that world what what
have you as it's just a data annotation
whether it's self-supervised or manual
by humans is um is a big part of the
software 2.0 world right I would say by
far in the industry if you're like
talking about the industry and how what
is the technology of what we have
available everything is supervised
learning so you need data sets of input
desired output and you need lots of it
and um there are three properties of it
that you need you need it to be very
large it needed to be accurate No
mistakes and you need it to be diverse
you don't want to uh just have a lot of
correct examples of one thing you need
to really cover the space of possibility
as much as you can and the more you can
cover the space of possible inputs the
better the algorithm will work at the
end now once you have really good data
sets that you're collecting curating
um and cleaning you can train uh your
neural net
um on top of that so a lot of the work
goes into cleaning those data sets now
as you pointed out it's probably it
could be the question is how do you
achieve a ton of uh if you want to
basically predict in 3D you need data in
3D to back that up so in this video we
have eight videos coming from all the
cameras of the system and this is what
they saw and this is the truth of what
actually was around there was this car
there was this car this car these are
the lane line markings this is geometry
of the road there's a traffic light in
this three-dimensional position you need
the ground truth
um and so the big question that the team
was solving of course is how do you how
do you arrive at that ground truth
because once you have a million of it
and it's large clean and diverse then
training a neural network on it works
extremely well and you can ship that
into the car and uh so there's many
mechanisms by which we collected that
training data you can always go for
human annotation you can go for
simulation as a source of ground truth
you can also go for what we call the
offline tracker
um
that we've spoken about at the AI day
and so on which is basically an
automatic reconstruction process for
taking those videos and recovering the
three-dimensional sort of reality of
what was around that car so basically
think of doing like a three-dimensional
reconstruction as an offline thing and
then understanding that okay there's 10
seconds of video this is what we saw and
therefore here's all the lane lines cars
and so on
and then once you have that annotation
you can train neural Nets to imitate it
and how difficult is the reconstruct the
3D reconstruction it's difficult but it
can be done so there's so the there's
overlap between the cameras and you do
the Reconstruction and there's uh
perhaps if there's any inaccuracy so
that's caught in The annotation step
uh yes the nice thing about The
annotation is that it is fully offline
you have infinite time you have a chunk
of one minute and you're trying to just
offline in a super computer somewhere
figure out where were the positions of
all the cars all the people and you have
your full one minute of video from all
the Angles and you can run all the
neural Nets you want and they can be
very efficient massive neural Nets there
can be neural Nets that can't even run
in the car later at this time so they
can be even more powerful neurons than
what you can eventually deploy so you
can do anything you want
three-dimensional reconstruction neural
Nets uh anything you want just to
recover that truth and then you
supervise that truth